there will soon be a new vaccine for the
coronavirus pandemic the question is
are these vaccines safe and can the
government force you to take them
when it comes down to lawyers they itch
for things like this 140 people
seriously injured by vaccines it's not
hypothetical
if you're right why wouldn't it follow
that the flu shot should be illegal
cdc is a vaccine company they are not
doing their job
as regulators we don't know what kova 19
vaccine will look like
anthony fauci put 500 millions of our
dollars into that vaccine
and now they've got a vaccine that is
too big to fail
would you urge the american people not
to take the vaccine
i'm not anti-vaccine i'm asking you the
question what if it was one in a
thousand oh of course i'm not gonna tell
one in a thousand people to die i think
you overstayed it
look at the vaccine insurance alan masks
work
we're gonna kill all these people
mandatory vaccination we're still gonna
make a profit so let's go ahead
certainly anybody who runs a
pharmaceutical company cares deeply
about not killing people
you can't sue them there's no discovery
there's nothing they never get caught
do you wear masks personally the flu
shot not only primes you for flu
and it primes you for coronavirus they
are unavoidably unsafe
[Music]
so look we've invited a lot of different
doctors to want to come and debate the
topic of covet 19 vaccine and everyone's
turned it down but when it comes down to
lawyers
they itch for things like this so it's a
different story when we're talking about
my two guests today
who by the way both of them have been a
guest on valuetainment before separately
on different topics
but today uh conversation came up this
week
a video popped up about what uh alan
dershowitz said that led to a dialogue
with uh
robert kennedy and then we said you know
what if we can set up a friendly debate
here together they both
agreed and so today's a special episode
we'll talk about a lot of different
things but
prior to going into it if you don't know
who uh alan dershowitz is his resume
is legendary 50 years he taught at
harvard
he's represented some of the most uh
interesting cases
o.j simpson a lot of different cases so
he said debate is
what he does for a living and on the
complete opposite side
we have robert kennedy where many call
him a
hero when it come down comes down to
environmental crusader he's also
obviously a lawyer
uh they've both written books uh allen's
recent book which you can get free on
kindle right now
uh is guilt by accusation it's on the
topic of the metoo movement
again i asked him do you want us to sell
it he said no let him go get the kindle
so
that's his discretion you can go get the
candle we'll put the link below as well
having said that gentlemen thank you so
much for being a guest on that payment
and agreeing to do this debate
thank you for having us patrick yeah
thank you so so first thing i want to do
is i want to share my screen and i'm
going to
uh i want the audience to see what led
us here a comment that you made on a
podcast you did
and then i'll go from there asking your
thoughts on it so here's what was said
in an interview a few weeks ago by allen
let's show a clip of this
let me put it very clearly you have no
constitutional right
to endanger the public and
spread the disease even if you disagree
you have no right not to be vaccinated
you have no right not to wear a mask you
have no right to
open up your business wait can i stop
you yeah
no right not to be vaccinated meaning
if they decide you have to be vaccinated
we have to be vaccinated
absolutely and if you refuse to be
vaccinated the state has the power
to literally take you to a doctor's
office
and plunge a needle into your arm if the
vaccine where is that in the
constitution
to prevent if the vaccination is
designed to prevent the spreading
disease
the vaccination is only to prevent a
disease that you will get
for example if there's a disease that
will kill you you have the right to
refuse that but you have no right to
refuse
to be vaccinated against a contagious
disease
public health the police power of the
constitution gives the state the power
to compel
that and there are cases in the united
states supreme court so now that
interview goes for a while so let me
bring you back to us here
uh alan those are some strong statements
you made obviously his reaction
a lot of people's reactions has your
position changed since making those
statements
on that interview statements i made on
the interview were
professional statements based on reading
supreme court cases
not expressing personal views they were
a
view i have strong personal views but
my constitutional views haven't changed
at all
let me be very clear i don't think this
issue is
going to come up in the near future
because
right now the new york times has a big
story today
uh in which they talk about uh how
there's going to be a limited number of
vaccines and people are going to be
waiting online to get them
so the issue is not going to be
confronted
uh as to mandatory vaccines
you know having said that i want to just
pause for one second and say
how important this debate is and how
privileged i am to participate and it
was so distinguished
uh a conversationalist as uh robert
kennedy
i of course knew his father i had
actually been offered a job to work with
his father when he was an attorney
general but
harvard offered me a job and i decided
to take it i was a great fan of
senator robert kennedy attorney general
robert kennedy and i think i consider
myself a friend of the kennedy family
and
i consider myself a friend of robert
kennedy i admire enormously the
environmental work he's done
and i think he's performed an important
function by raising issues
about uh vaccination we as you'll see in
this
conversation will disagree we'll
probably agree
on more things than people will be
will be surprised at our level of
agreement but on the issue of
constitutionality i am confident that
this supreme court would follow uh
supreme court president
president from 1905 and would say if
there is a safe
and that's crucially important effective
measure that could significantly reduce
the contagious impact of a deadly
disease
like the current pandemic virus
that the state would have the power to
either directly
compel vaccination or for example
condition
young students coming to school on being
vaccinated
or people doing other things that might
result in contagion being vaccinated so
no i haven't changed my professional
constitutional opinion
but as as robert will tell you we've had
conversations offline
and he has persuaded me uh about a
number of things
relating to the health and safety and
efficacy of
vaccines so i've learned a lot from our
conversations and i hope people will
learn something from our conversations
today
but the constitutional issue in my mind
remains the same
so it's important to unpack that
constitutionally your remaining same
position to say
if the government wanted to mandate and
make
us take a vaccine we can't say anything
to it that position is not changing
that's right as long as the vaccination
is safe and effective
an example if you have somebody who has
unique
uh vulnerability to vaccinations
uh that person might get a medical
exemption
the issue of religious exemption um is
something the courts have
considered most recently the supreme
court did just
in the last day or two create religious
exemptions
for private schools religious schools
in terms of whether employment laws uh
operate on religious schools so
uh we would have to see what the court
would say about religious exemptions but
as a general matter a healthy person
who simply has an ideological objection
to vaccinations as such not to this
particular vaccination because of health
reasons or
vulnerability the supreme court would i
predict hold
that the state could in one way or
another
compel vaccination either directly or as
a condition
of people engaging in public activities
or activities that could create
contagion yeah that's my position
well that's very important to know
because there's your personal beliefs
which is completely different
than what you think will be able to be
mandated so having said that robert i
know you've seen this before
and uh uh you've seen uh when this
statement was made and
in one case uh uh alan even said he'd be
willing to debate robert kennedy on this
topic which kind of led to us wanting to
do this debate
what was your initial reaction of
watching what alan said
and what has changed since you and him
have had calls together offline
well i want to begin
thanking atlanta for participating in
this by the way
patrick you're familiar and that one's
familiar with my voice
i want to apologize for that at the
outset it's really bad in the morning
and
alan can only do this in the morning but
hopefully it'll get better as we
uh as we proceed i want to thank alan
for participating in this debate
i've actually been trying to do a debate
on this issue
for 15 years um i've
asked peter hotez as paul off
as all of the major leaders of um
who are promoting vaccines and none of
them have
and i think it's really important for
our democracy
to have to be able to have spirited
civil discussions about important issues
like this this is an issue that has been
on the news
24 hours a day for the last four months
and yet there's no debate happening
about this
it's all kind of a a repetition
of these government orthodoxies and
government proclamations
and democracy functions only when we
have the free flow of information and
policy is best often crafted
in the furnace of heated spirited debate
it's part of our constitutional system
it's part of americans
tradition we invented a free speech
in these countries of the first
amendment and it ought to be something
that we
celebrate and that we model for the
world it shouldn't be something where
you now have democratic leaders like
adam schiff
calling on social media sites to censor
debate about an important
government issue that shouldn't happen
so i'm very grateful
that alan who i know loves the first
amendment
are actually agreeing to debate on an
issue in which
he disadvantage because i've spent 15
years working on this issue
i'm at a big disadvantage for him and
when it comes to talking about
constitutional law and i'm going to try
to keep a lot of the state on my side of
the issue
[Laughter]
let me start out by saying i don't agree
with alan's initial
and this is a very small disagreement
because alan and i have talked a lot
offline and i think we've come to a
place where we really
believe this this is going to be a
conversation not a debate because i
think
on most of the issues we are in
agreement and he made the qualifiers
when he came
up and he said if it's safe if it's
effective
and i think those are the big gifts
that's the playground with this debate
is really happening and i think
in the end he and i would end up in the
same place
i will make a minor dispute
which is the jacobsen case which was
decided in 1905
was not a case where the state was
claiming
the power to go into somebody's home and
plunge a needle into their arm and kick
down their door and take them by force
the um
jacobson actually was a guy who was
resisting
taking a small box vaccine he was from
cambridge massachusetts
and the penalty for not taking the
vaccine was a five dollar fine so it was
like a traffic ticket
he decided to take it he had been
injured in a previous vaccine so i
didn't want to take this one
he took the case the supreme court he
lost
and the remedy was he paid a five dollar
fine so
i think it's a big there's a big there's
a
there's a big constitutional chasm
between you know that remedy which is
paying a fine and actually going in and
holding somebody down and forcibly
injecting them and i
i don't i'm not convinced the supreme
court of the united states
at this point would would um would
uphold
that kind of law nine to zero or eight
to one
at all so let me just say that i let me
now go to the initial place
i think we're in agreement i think al
and i are both in agreement
that this should be a voluntary program
and if there's mandates they should be
as an
ultimate final dramatic drastic
remedy and that really
and and the question is why can't we do
a voluntary program
when ellen and i were kids you know
people wanted to get vaccinated
there was no fear of the statements
of polio vaccines and people had a
tremendous trust
in our health regulatory officials and
today that trust has evaporated to the
extent where now 50
of the people who are polled in this
country are saying they may not take the
covet vaccine and 27
are hard no is it even before the
vaccine is developed
why is that happening and that's the
question i think we really have to
ask ourselves why do so many americans
no longer trust our regulatory officials
and trust this process
and one of the reasons is you know
vaccines are very very interesting
and very different kind of of medical
prerogative
because it is a
it's a remedy that is being it's a
medical intervention
that is being given to perfectly healthy
people
to prevent somebody else from getting
sick
and it's the only medicine that's given
to healthy people
so you would want and particularly to
children who have a whole lifetime in
front of them
so you would expect that we would want
that particular intervention
to have particularly rigorous guarantees
that it's
safe because you're saying to somebody
we are going to
make you make this sacrifice
for the greater good you have no health
problems of zero risk
this is is we are going to force you to
undergo a medical
intervention and our side of the bargain
should be we want this to be completely
safe
in fact what we know about vaccines and
this is
from hhs's own studies a
a a 2010 study by the agency for
healthcare research
i was commissioned to look at vaccine
injury because
edc for many years had been saying
vaccine injury
only occurs one in a million but what
ahrq found with the federal agency they
looked at one hmo
which was a harvard pilgrim hmo and they
did a
machine cluster analysis on in other
words
artificial intelligence counting a very
very accurate counting system
based at the actual rate of vaccine
injury
is 2.6 percent that means
140 people get seriously injured by
vaccines
and we want to and do we have a right
to say we are going to impose this
intervention
on people where there's a 1 in 40 chance
that you may get
injured in order to
in order to protect hypothetical people
catching that particular disease
and for anybody and this i think is
something that
alan really has to i think alan that you
need to come to terms with in terms of
crafting your own arguments about this
it's not hypothetical that vaccines
cause injury and that injuries are not
rare
the vaccine courts have paid out four
billion dollars and the threshold for
getting back into a vaccine court and
getting a judgment
hhs admits that fewer than one percent
of people
who are injured ever even get to court
the other thing is vaccines are
zero liability so this is an industry
that went to congress in 1996 and they
had a
a different attendance vaccine at that
time that was called a causing brain
injury of
one out of every 300 people
and they said to congress we cannot make
this we cannot make vaccines safely
they are unavoidably unsafe that is the
phrase
in the statute unavoidably unsafe
the only reason that we're going to
continue to make vaccines
is if you give us complete blanket
immunity from liability
and congress gave it to them so hey you
have a product
that that if it injured you no matter
how
negligent the company was no matter how
sloppy that line protocols
no matter how toxic the ingredients that
you choose to use no matter how grievous
your injury
you cannot sue that company and that
company therefore
has no incentive to make that product
safe and that should be troubling to any
of
us who are part of the legal system that
is saying
we are going to force people to take
this intervention
look uh i agree with much of what
uh robert has said first of all i
completely agree the supreme court
decision
in the jacobson case in 1905 is not
binding on the issue of whether or not
you can compel somebody to take the
vaccine
the logic of the opinion however not the
holding the logic
of the opinion and subsequent opinions
including some by justice oliver holmes
strongly suggests that the courts today
would
allow some form of compulsion if the
conditions that we talked about were met
safe effective exemptions in
appropriate cases
you talked about healthy people
being compelled to take a vaccine
which is not designed to help them of
course it's also designed to help them
but the major function is to make sure
that they don't become typhoid mary's
and spread the disease to other people
but when you take a vaccine you also
increase the chances that you will not
get the terrible terrible disease
i think you're going to have to concede
robert that
the smallpox vaccine had an enormous
positive
impact on wiping smallpox from the face
of the earth
smallpox was a dreaded dreaded dreaded
disease
a black plague back in many many
centuries ago if there had been a
vaccine back then
could have saved probably millions of
lives we don't know what covet 19
vaccine will look like but
on the assumption and here we have a
real argument on the assumption
that it would be effective and would
stop the pandemic
and would cause some injury to some
people
then you have to ask how the courts
would strike the balance all the wendell
holmes
once made an analogy to uh in an
unrelated case to being drafted into the
army um
when you're a young 18 year old healthy
person
and we have a draft as we had in the
second world war we don't have it now
but at that point in time a young 18
year old was told look
congress has given the army complete
exemption we're not
liable if you're shot by the nazis or by
the the japanese you have to risk your
life
in order to protect other innocent
people in the country and
it's not a perfect analogy obviously but
it does
show that the courts have given to the
government
the authority to sometimes make
decisions
that require you to sacrifice your life
i have to tell you i don't become
personal about this but i don't think
there's any family
in the history of america that has ever
made more sacrifices
in the public interest than the kennedy
family you know we broke all of our
hearts
to see how much sacrifice the kennedy
family personally made
in order to particularly robert kennedy
who put himself
in harm's way so many times on behalf of
the civil rights movement people forget
how much he put himself in harm's way on
behalf of israel you know he was a great
friend of israel a great supporter of
israel
and the horrible man who killed him
killed him because
he was a palestinian who hated bobby
kennedy
seniors views sacrifice is part of
the american tradition and the americans
owe
the kennedy family an enormous debt of
gratitude for their sacrifices now those
were voluntary sacrifices
president kennedy went to dallas knowing
there were risks
robert kennedy went to los angeles
knowing there were risks by the way i
was working on his campaign the night
i was woken up in the middle of the
night to learn the horrible horrible
horrible
tragic news and
those were voluntary acts and obviously
we're talking about a very different
thing we're talking about involuntary
acts
but being drafted is an involuntary act
again
to mention the kennedy family the oldest
brother of the kennedy family
volunteered to serve in the army and was
killed in combat as a great hero
but there were others uh who didn't
volunteer
many of my own relatives served abroad
so we demand sacrifices and we don't
demand
perfection i think both robert and i
agree
that we live in an age and it's a
terrible time that we live in
where everything has become politicized
you mentioned that when we were kids
i remember not being able to swim in the
summers of
1953-45 because of polio
my friend died after being on a
a lung machine and the blessing that we
all made to uh
salt and sageman for developing uh
the vaccine but there were consequences
people took the vaccine in
and did suffer in the end no polio was
was wiped out and you know we live in a
very divisive
age let me mention one other point that
i think we should be discussing today
the new york times has a very
interesting story about
who the vaccine will be offered to the
time story is not about
mandatory it's about people wanting it
and robert and i
completely agree that the program should
begin by giving it only to volunteers
we should only get to this terrible
tragic choice issue
in the end if it's absolutely essential
that
people who don't want to be vaccinated
have to be vaccinated to get the kind of
hurt immunity we all agree with that
but we live in such a divided time that
everything has become politicized
on july 4th the reverend uh fair khan
made a speech to almost a million people
in which he urged uh black people not to
take the vaccine
because we know the history of how black
people were experimented
on during the terrible tuskegee time
and yet black people and latino people
and people of color
are the most vulnerable to the illness
uh
is that a smart thing for farrakhan to
have urged his community
the number of of people of color who
have refused to who are indicated a
refusal to take the vaccine
is i think slightly higher according to
the report
than the number of people not of color
who are refusing to take the vaccine
i understand that i understand the
suspicion
that our country is generated among
people people don't trust people anymore
i wrote an article in early march right
in the beginning of this
right at the beginning of this i wrote
an article and the title was
trust science but be skeptical of
scientists
and at that point i pointed to two
things that were being argued by
scientists including the world health
organization which i generally support
saying don't wear masks number one and
number two
the covid19 is not contagious
by air it has no aerosol contagion
you know that article you wrote that
article no i wrote the article against
it
against my article saying don't believe
that
masks work number one if they didn't
work why would so many doctors be using
them and why would it be so necessary
for doctors to have them
and second i don't believe that there's
no aerosol transmission
the disease could not have developed so
quickly around the world
just by touching surfaces so i challenge
the medical establishment on that and i
turned out of course
as we all know to be right we know
there's aerosol transmission we know
masks have an impact whether they help
you who are wearing it or whether they
only help you and transmitting it
but i would like to throw a question out
to robert i think i know the answer
robert would you be against a law
that mandated the wearing of masks in
public for everybody
even by people who don't approve of the
wearing of mass because
you know masks don't kill you they're
not they're not they don't pose the risk
that vaccine do but they do deprive you
of freedom do you think the state the
government
has the legitimate constitutional power
to mandate the wearing of masks by
people
who refuse to wear masks let me come
back to that let me address some of the
other things because i think that's
actually a complex question and i think
the science is very controversial
let me address some of the earlier
things that you said first
um one is this is a rather esoteric
discussion
um and and one that you know i'm not
gonna
really drag you into other than to say
this
the proposition and the theology
at smallpox and polio were abolished
due to vaccination is controversial
that is not a proposition that is
universally accepted
and i mean if you notice all the
infectious diseases whether it was
scurvy or tuberculosis for which there
were no vaccines
um along with peripheral fever and
diphtheria and
pertussis and measles all disappeared at
the same time
without vaccination now
cdc actually examined that because it
became
such a part of the orthodoxy of you know
vaccines that that the idea that
smallpox and polio were abolished
because of vaccines
and these other diseases they did
john hopkins cdc in 2000
in a comprehensive study of that
proposition the study was published
in pediatrics which is the journal for
the american association of pediatrics
which is
kind of a readout fortification for
vaccine orthodoxy so it was
a it's a publication very very friendly
in support of a vaccination
for people who want to look up this
audience i'm the
lead author is guy or g-u-i-e-r
and the conclusion of that study is
that the abolishment of
mortalities from infectious diseases
that took place
during the first half of the 20th
century
had virtually nothing to do with
vaccines it had everything to do with
sanitation with nutrition
with hygiene with electric refrigerators
with reduction in population densities
and essentially engineering solution
clean water
good food um and that was uh
and actually there was a guy called
edward cass who was
head of harvard medical school at that
time who gave a very very famous speech
in which he warned that people who were
promoting vaccines and other
technologies would try to take
credit for those reductions in
mortalities from infectious disease and
he said beware of them because they'll
try to monitor that
they'll try to monetize them and use
that to increase
their power and their prestige so it's
something that you might
look at again it's called guy or
g-u-i-e-r
um i agree with you there was tremendous
faith
in vaccination during that period when
you grew up i grew up
allen we had three vaccines and all of
them were deemed as necessary there were
fear diseases
today's kids have to take 72 vaccines
72 doses of 16 vaccines in order to stay
in school
and that explosion of new vaccination
came
in 1989 after the passage
of vica vaccine act
the vaccine had a blanket immunity from
liability
to vaccine companies and so those
companies
all of a sudden looked around and they
said holy cow now we've got a product
where we are completely excused from the
highest cost from uh
that flicks every other medical product
which is the downstream liability for
injuries that's the biggest cause for
every medicine
not only that the vaccines have another
exemption that most people don't
know about they are the only medical
product that does not have to be safety
tested against a placebo
and that is at exemption
is an artifact of cdc's
legacy as a public health service which
was a quasi-military agency which is why
people at cdc have military ranks like
surgeon general and they wear uniforms
the vaccine program was conceived as a
national security defense against
biological attacks on our country
and they wanted to make sure that if the
russians
attacked us the biological age and
anthrax or something like that
we could quickly formulate a vaccine and
and deploy it to 200 million american
civilians without regulatory impediments
they said if we call it a medicine we're
going to have to test it and that takes
five years double-blind placebo testing
so let's call it something else we'll
call it a biologic
and we'll exempt biologics from safety
testing
so not a single one of the vaccines that
72 vaccines now
our children have ever been tested
against a placebo
and i in fact sued hhs in 2016 and said
show me any placebo studies that you
have for any vaccines
and they were unable to do so none of
them haven't tested it and
you don't have to sue them like i did
anybody can go on their cell phone
and look up manufacturers insert
hepatitis b
vaccine cardiovaccine polio vaccine you
know how many days the current polio
vaccine
you know how many days it was safety
tested for on
48 hours the hepatitis b
vaccine the glax aversion was four days
the merch version five days that means
that if the baby they gave that to
had a seizure on day six it never
happened
if the baby died on day six it never
if the baby got food allergies that were
diagnosed two years later
it never happened if the baby got autism
which is not diagnosed till
four years of age 4.2 years of age it
never happened
autoimmune diseases you cannot see those
if you have short-term studies and you
can't see
any risk if you don't test against the
placebo
and my question is nobody knows
because of that nobody knows risk
profile
or any vaccine that is currently on the
schedule
and that means nobody can say with any
scientific certainty
that vaccine is averting more injuries
and deaths than it's causing
and my question is how in the heck
can we be mandated to children
that they take a medical product for
which we do not know the risks
and to me that is criminal
and you know we talked we started this
discussion by talking about
how do you avoid the whole discussion
about
mandating vaccines the way that you do
that is you have a transparent process
where people see that the vaccine is
going to be tested they see
that it's tested fairly against a
placebo
that um that it is there's
long-term tests that are going to be
evidenced by all of these difficulties
and and that it's transparent and open
and yet what we've seen from the current
group of covet vaccines is none of
that's happening
they're skipping keys key parts of the
test um
the internet vaccine which is the lead
candidate skip the animal testing
altogether
when they came to human testing they
tested it on 45 people they had a
high-dose group of 15 people a medium
dose group
15 people on a low growth group of 15
people
in the low dose group one of the people
who are so
sick from the vaccine they had to be
hospitalized that's six percent
in the high dose group three people got
so sick they had to be hospitalized
that's twenty percent they're going
ahead
and making two billion doses of that
vaccine
and by the way the people that they test
them on
alan are not typical americans
they use what they call exclusionary
criteria they
are only giving these vaccines in these
tests that they're doing
to the healthiest people if you look at
their exclusionary idea
you cannot be pregnant you cannot be
overweight you must have never smoked a
cigarette you must have never vaped
you must have no respiratory problems in
your family
you can't suffer asthma you can't have
diabetes you can't have
um rheumatoid arthritis or ottawa any
autoimmune disease there has to be no
history of seizure family these are the
people they're testing the vaccine on
but that's not who they're going to give
them to
what happens if these people are like
the avengers they're like superman you
can shoot them with a bullet and they
won't go down
what happens when they give them to the
typical american you know
sally six-pack and joe bag of donuts
who's 50 pounds overweight and that's
diabetes
what is you know what is going to happen
then you're not going to see 20
you're going to see a lot of people
dropping death these people lost
consciousness they had to go to hospital
they had huge fevers
and they're the healthiest people in the
world so any other medicine
allen that had that kind of profile in
its original phase one study would be
doa the problem is
anthony fauci put 500 million dollars of
our dollars
into that vaccine he owns half the
patent
he has five guys working for him we're
entitled to collect
royalties from that so you have a
corrupt
system and now they've got a vaccine
that is too big to fail and instead of
saying hey this was a terrible terrible
mistake
you're saying we are going to order 2
billion
doses of this and and you got to
understand alan with these covet
vaccines
these companies are playing with house
money they're not
spending anything on it and they have no
liability
so if they kill 20 people or 200 people
2 000 people in their clinical trials
big deal they have zero liability and
guess what
if wasted money their money because
we're giving them the money to play with
oh you know people like me and people in
our community
are looking at this process and we're
saying
uh you know whatever comes out of that
process we don't want to take it
because we're seeing how the sausage
gets made
and it's really sickening no medical
product
in the world would be able to go
forward with the profile that modernized
let me just respond because i think
we're coming to some common ground here
i have no doubt that transparency and
testing is essential
uh i don't understand why
there isn't placebo testing and other
testing
later after the initial vaccine
so there are many phases in a vaccine we
have an emergency now
and we may have to in fact develop a
vaccine and make it available to people
without placebo testing without
diversity testing we may have to do that
but there's no reason
why over time we can't do the
traditional testing
say with polio or smallpox that are now
part of our history uh and have now
existed for so many years
obviously at this point there's no
reason not to be able to do the placebo
and the other kinds of
human testing the article in the times
that i referred to
made a very interesting point it said
that the people who are most vulnerable
to the disease
are the people who probably won't be
part of the original testing
the testing is as you said done mostly
on people who are
quite healthy but isn't there a natural
test that occurs
you say the pharmaceutical injury has
nothing to lose but look at what
happened to the pharmaceutical companies
that put forward some of the opiates
they have been driven out of business
their names have been taken off
buildings uh they
are regarded as pariahs in the world
today
certainly anybody who runs a
pharmaceutical company cares deeply
about not killing people
and even if the government doesn't
mandate this kind of testing
and even if they give them exemption
from financial liability
surely good people and i think we assume
that
people who run companies today i have a
friend
who's trying to develop one of the
vaccines and and he's doing it without
profit
he feels so strongly about the need to
uh vaccinate people around the world
so i think you overstate it when you say
that the people who are developing these
vaccines
have no concern whatsoever whether
people
live or die i think they do have a
concern i i think the government has
eliminated their financial liability
but would you would you be sad
and the other thing is you say there's
no testing but i
i'm not the expert i'm not the medical
journal reader but i've read enough
medical journals to know
that there is a lot of natural testing
you cite some of it
you cite some of the arguments that say
that over years people get autism people
get this people get that
those results don't come from the
initial testing
that allowed the product to go forward
they come from
great universities medical schools and
public health institutions
that continue to test products over time
and report to the public the results of
those products
uh robert here's the here's the answer
you raised a bunch of questions one is
the opiate people got busted
alan and and by the way no they were not
moral people they knew what they were
doing they're killing
uh 56 000 american young kids a year
knowing what they were doing or kids
every year that were killed in the
20-year vietnam war these are not moral
companies
and they only got busted because
plaintiff's attorneys could sue them
and they got the the discovery documents
and walked them down to the u.s
attorney's office and said hey there's
criminal behavior here
that can never happen in the vaccine
space you can't sue them there's no
discovery there's no depositions there's
no
class action suit there's no multi-disc
on district litigation
there's no interrogatories nothing they
never get caught now they use four
companies
that make all of our vaccines all 72 of
the vaccine shots are now mandated for
our children
every one of them is a convicted serial
felon axo sanofi pfizer merk
in the past 10 years just in the last
decade
those companies have paid 35 billion
dollars in criminal penalties
damages fines are lying to doctors for
deprawning signs for falsifying signs
for killing hundreds of thousands of
americans knowingly
and getting away with it by ox which was
merged the biggest vaccine producer
biox which was their flagship product in
2007 was a
pill that they marketed as a headache
pill
that caused heart attacks they knew it
caused heart attacks because they saw
them in the
signals in their clinical trials he
didn't tell the american public
and they killed between 120 000 and 500
000 americans who did not need to die
and
most of those americans were people who
had
rheumatoid arthritis or they had
headaches and migraines
they took that bill that bill leaving
and and by the way when we sued them we
got spreadsheets from their bean
counters
where they said we're going to kill all
these people
we're still going to make a profit so
let's go ahead
and no because nobody can justify that i
agree with that
and they ended up they should have all
gone to prison and said they spent they
paid a seven billion dollar fine but how
can anybody it
requires a cognitive dissonance or
people who understand
the corporate called the criminal
corporate cultures of these four
companies
to believe that they're doing this and
every other product
that they are that they have but they're
not doing it with vaccines
they are and i just want to answer your
other question
no placebo testing does not take place
after the clinical trials and the reason
for that
is that hhs has adopted
a very unethical guidance that says
it is unethical once a vaccine is
licensed recommended
it is unethical to do
implicit trials or compare vaccinated
persons on vaccinated people
there are scientists who do it but
they're punished for it
they're it's very difficult for them to
publish they get their
uh their funding cut off because nobody
wants
any study that is going to reveal the
truth about vaccine injuries so it just
does not happen
look it's very important that you're
making these points because we live in a
democracy
and nobody is going to compel a vaccine
unless
you get democratic approval legislatures
are going to have to pass
laws doing that and you should testify
about this your
your voice should be heard but in the
end
how do you respond when the american
public has listened to you
listen to your argument they're very
persuasive and they're very convincing
and they
have an impact on people like me with
open minds uh
and yet in the end there's a vote by the
legislature
and the legislature votes to compel
vaccinations in the public interest just
the way the legislature votes to draft
young people
to fight wars in which they will die
in a democracy don't you have to
follow the will of the majority i agree
transparency is all important
and and and let's shift the debate
because you said you wanted to answer
the question
let's take it out of vaccine for one
second because i think it helps
analytically i'm a law professor for 50
years so i always do hypotheticals hypos
so let's assume the legislature now
passes a law at every 50 states and the
united states congress passes the law
requiring everybody to wear a mask when
they're outdoors
and you say well i'm not so sure that
masks are
helpful maybe they are maybe they aren't
congress has hearings
congress makes a determination that on
balance
they are helpful wouldn't you agree
that it would be constitutional let's
start with constitutional and then
desirable
wouldn't you agree that would be
constitutional to mandate the wearing of
masks even if people have
political ideological medical
religious objections because a the
wearing of the mask
is only an inconvenience maybe it'll
cause a little irritation by some people
that will require
you know a topical uh pharmaceutical
uh and it has the potential not to save
the world but to improve the possibility
of not having communicable diseases
wouldn't you agree that
mandatory mask wearing would be
constitutional
well if i accepted all of your
precedence
then perhaps i would the thing is i know
a lot about
the math and my organization chd has not
taken a position
on on um but i have read
um well i've read at least three met
reviews
involving hundreds of studies on maths
and the majority of the studies in fact
there's a bmj
study from 2015 it says that
the mass actually likely to spread the
disease
and to make you less healthy because the
carbon dioxide that you're breathing
and the people who wear the mass are
more likely to get sick
i'm not saying that that's my position
i'm just saying
there's a lot of contrary science out
there
do you do you wear a mask personally
if the science was clear if the science
was clear that might be much more
sympathetic to your view let me ask you
this
let me just answer the other question
you had you said we have to rely on the
majority
well i grew up in the state of virginia
alan
when i grew up it was illegal because
the majority voted
that it was illegal for a black man to
marry a white woman
to vote so the majority is not now in a
democracy you have the courts there that
protect our rights
um and unfortunately we are in a
situation today
where we have tremendous corruption not
only in congress which is receiving
which receives more money from
pharmaceutical companies than
any other industry pharmaceutical gifts
in lobbying
twice the amount that oil and gas which
is the next big one
four times with defense in aerospace
there are more lobbyists
armed lobbyists in congress and there
are members of congress in the senate so
we have lost the um
you know the legislative independence
that body
and the unfortunately allen
let the agencies are also captured
now you know about agency capture
it happens everywhere and i absolutely
epa
my entire life we just pump sued the
the uh epa we just said monsanto
we got an historic judgement 12 billion
dollar settlement
in the monsanto case and i was part of
that trial team and one of the things
that happened during that trial
is that epa took a position against us
they took a position that
at a glyphosate roundup does not cause
cancer
as it turns out we got an internal
memorandum that showed that the head of
the pesticide division
in epa was actually working secretly for
monsanto
and killing studies and twisting studies
and ghost riding studies
to falsify the science look you're doing
it
we were able to show that to the jury
now imagine this that's epa which is an
independent agency
imagine this fda
that's 50 of its budget from
vaccine companies from the industry 50
the cdc
has an 11.5 billion budget and 4.9
billion of that
is buying and selling and distributing
vaccines
cdc is a vaccine company it owns
57 vaccine patents so it can make money
on every sale of a vaccine nih owns
hundreds of vaccines patents
nih owns half the patent for the
modernity vaccine
there's five individuals in nih and the
rules at nih if you're a scientist or an
official who worked on a vaccine
you're allowed to collect 150 000 a year
in royalties on sales that vaccine makes
these regulatory agencies are actually
vaccine companies
the the vaccine marketing sales part of
those agencies
is the tale that is now wagging the
regulatory talk
they are not doing their job as
regulators
and in fact the senior scientists
at cdc today the senior vaccine safety
scientist
who's been invited he's still at he was
a senior scientist there for 18 years
he is the author or co-author on all of
the major studies that cec
has produced on vaccine safety and
particularly the studies that show the
vaccine does not cause autism
his name is dr william thompson three
years ago he came
forward and he said uh
we have been ordered to fake all the
science
of the last decade on autism and any
anything in fact
we were in the major study which is
called the stefano 2004's the most cited
study on this subject
anyone pubmed and he said in that study
we found out that
black boys who get the mmr vaccine had a
363 percent greater
risk of getting an autism diagnosis and
black boys who waited
after 36 months he said
he was ordered to come into a conference
room
with all that data with his four other
co-authors by their
cdc pause frank de stefano who then
ordered them to destroy that data
in front of them in cdc headquarters and
then published that study saying
there is no effect so you have an agency
that is really just an arm of industry
and the people
who are in my community who are being
derided
and vilified these mothers who are chili
and your children are being vilified in
the press
who are saying wait a minute we have
read the studies the scientific studies
we have read about the industry
corruption we need to talk about this
they're being silenced by the press
they're not allowed to tell their
stories and nobody is
talking about a single member of
anderson cooper's staff or sanjay kupa
has made
any effort to talk to bill thompson and
he has been begging to be subpoenaed
and he's still at cdc look the reason
to do this debate is because i think you
perform an important function
by bringing out some of these ties some
of these connections you perform an
important function
when you bring lawsuits against corrupt
pharmaceutical companies but
my question is this knowing all that you
know now and putting aside the issue of
let's assume
we didn't have mandatory vaccinations
let's assume you win that debate
and it's only voluntary vaccinations now
and they come forward with a vaccine
that they say
will stem the tide of the pandemic and
you're allowed to go
on television on anderson cooper would
you
urge all the american people not to take
the vaccine
would you become part of the campaign
not to take the vaccine
if it were vomiting
oh no i'm not any vaccine
people call me any vaccine because it's
a way of marginalizing me and silencing
me
i am asking you the question i'm not
alan i've antibiotic trying to get
mercury
out of fish for 37 years and nobody
calls me any fish
i support everyone 100 but
let me just television what would you
tell the american public
if the vaccine were available and if you
were invited say to speak
to members of the black community
members latino community
members of the general uh american
community
and they said
it does what okay says it's going to do
which is you give one shot you can
lifetime immunity
and there are vanishingly rare
serious injuries oh well i don't mind
you know
jab sight redness pitching forget about
it i don't care
i'm talking about deaths or brain damage
one in a million
that may be acceptable in that case
and and it works and i'd say i'm
i tell people yeah i'm gonna get it
let's go ahead and get it
what if it was
no of course not i'm not going to tell 1
000 people to die
so that on 999 people can get can avoid
grovid particularly since the case
fatality rate for
i mean like a healthy person has
basically
zero chance of time from covenants i
don't think you know
you need to give it to a tremendous
number of people to save one life
and and we and the problem is with this
vaccine is
we don't know if the vaccine is going to
kill more people when you start giving
it to those people with
comorbidities 54 of americans
now has diabetes overweight rheumatoid
arthritis
they're smoking they have 54 of us
i'm not even talking about smokers and
vapers 54
of us has chronic disease they're
they're testing it on one group and
they're going to give it to another and
we need to know what the risk factor is
and the people that they give it to and
i i agree with that let me put you in
let me just say that but completely
thought i was going to be
made before you know i've suited the epa
for many years and it's captive agency
what would happen if epa made half of
its annual budget
selling coal that's what you got with
these regulatory agencies
you're performing an important function
doing this let me ask you another
question what if we had a system which
said this
you have two choices one you can have
the vaccine
or two you can refuse to take the
vaccine but if you refuse to take the
vaccine
you have to remain in quarantine until
such
time as the pandemic is basically passed
so it's your option
the one option you have you don't have
the third option that is not taking the
vaccine
and mingling with the public and risking
other people
getting covet not only young people
although young people do die
the broadway actor who had his leg
amputated
and recently died tragically without any
pre-existing conditions
what if we gave people that option
quarantine is the option
for refusing to accept the vaccine but
you don't have the third option
of refusing to accept the vaccine and
walking around the public without masks
the problem is you know that sounds like
a reasonable
position the problem is it's not the
world
the way the world works and let me
explain why
here's how the world works and the best
analogy
is the is the flu vaccine
so a flu vaccine is very much like the
coronavirus vaccine but we've had the
flu vaccine for 90 years so
every year it's fine tuned and we and
and perfected
and originally they told us the flu
vaccine you'll get one shot you'll have
immunity for life
and then it turned out no we we need to
get it every year
because there are variations of the flu
same thing is highly likely to happen
with corona virus
of the cochrane collaboration which is
the ultimate arbiter for
vaccine safety it is you know it is the
highest authority
and the british medical journal have
done three giant meta reviews
on few on on the flu vaccine literature
so they look at all the literature that
exists the peer review literature that
is on pubmed
i think 127 studies
they did it in 2010 2014 and 2017.
here's what they find cdc said the flu
vaccine is 35
effective that's what they claim
cochrane collaboration said
no it you have to give 100 flu
shots to prevent one case of flu number
one
number two there is zero evidence that
the flu
shot prevents any hospitalizations or
any deaths number three
the flu shot transmits the flu
in fact if you get a flu shot you're six
times more likely to give somebody else
the flu
and if you didn't get the flu shot and
this is true allen for many many other
shots for the polio vaccine which you
know about
is so good at transmitting giving polio
to other people that seventy percent of
the polio cases
in the world today come from the vaccine
so let me ask you a specific question
the chickenpox if you go to the
chickenpox
um manufacturer's insert
it says if you get this chickenpox
vaccine you should not go near a
pregnant woman for six weeks
or anybody who doesn't mean a compromise
same with me
the same with pertussis you become an
asymptomatic carrier
so it's a you're not guaranteeing and in
fact
the the uh the astrazeneca
vaccine the oxford vaccine which is the
the other leader when they gave it to
monkeys
the monkeys continue to transmit the
disease
and bill gates and fauci have been going
on tv saying you know we may get a
vaccine that protects you but
you may still be transmitting it so why
are you going to lock that guy up in a
house
look like all the people out who've been
who are now asymptomatic carriers
because they've got a vaccine
let me agree with you first of all if
they develop a vaccine that only
prevents you from getting it but doesn't
prevent you from transmitting it
i would not be in favor of uh compelling
that vaccine and i think the supreme
court would not
accept that as a rationale but i want to
ask you a direct question i'm 81 i'm
almost 82 years old
my doctor who i love and admire says to
me every year come october you must get
the flu
vaccine you must get the vaccine against
pneumonia
uh you must get the vaccine whatever it
is against shingles
i listen to my doctor who i love and
admire
has been taking care of me for years
should i instead listen to you
and not take the flu vaccine nobody
should listen to me
people need to do the science themselves
and i would say to you
no um listen to your doctor what reagan
said about
about gorbachev trust but verified
you look at the vaccine inserts alan
yeah look at some of the science and i
would say
you know my i in a million years
i would not take the flu shot and i'll
tell you why because this is what
cochrane and bmj have found
people who take the flu shot are
protected against
that strain of flu but they're 4.4 times
more likely to get a non-flu infection
and you might find
a lot of people do that they get the flu
shot and then they get sick
they're usually not getting the flu or
getting something that is
indistinguishable from the flu because
the flu shot
gives you something called pathogenic
priming
if it it injures your immune system so
that you're more likely to get a non-flu
viral upper respiratory infection in
fact
the pentagon published a story and you
can cite as it's by wolf w-o-l-f-e
in january of this year in which the ace
had
the flu shot not only primes you for flu
and it primes you for coronavirus if you
get they gave
flu a placebo group and they had a
vaccine group because they wanted for
many of military readiness to see if the
flu shot was prophylactic against
component virus
what they found is actually the people
who got the flu shot were 36
more likely to get coronavirus and
that's not a
that's not a lone study we found
six other major studies that say the
same thing if you get the flu shot
you're more likely to get coconut virus
and this is what the science says and
you should not listen to me
nobody should i understand
so let me understand the implications of
your position on the flu shot
uh not only uh would you not take the
flu shot
and urge me to look at the science and
in the end decide not to take the flu
shot
because it's too dangerous but you would
also if i take the implications of your
position accurately
outlaw the flu shot make it illegal
because in your view and in the view of
the scientists you
quote the flu shot causes more harm than
good and and increases the chances
of us all getting the coronavirus do i
understand the implications of your view
correctly
yeah but i wouldn't i wouldn't take um
that sort of extreme position what i
would say is
we should have vaccines but
it's we shouldn't have one size fits all
mandates there may be
some situations where even a flu shot
would be beneficial to somebody because
a flu shot
is not completely ineffective it does
probably
give you protection against that year's
flu
strain if they get it right and there
could be a situation where somebody's
life depended on getting that flu shot
but
to mandate the flu shot population wide
i think
is criminal and i think it's you know
look all you have to do alan and just
what cochran said
is look what's happened to longevity
in the elderly since we started
mandating the flu shot to elderly people
those are the people who their their
life expectancy had
dramatically gone down as the flu shot
proliferated and if you see you know the
people who died during the covet
vaccinate
during the covid crisis
and there's no science on this but it's
observational
it tended to be people who got their flu
shots people who were in nursing homes
who will all get flu shots people who
are first responders who can't
respect i don't understand the
implications of your position if if
you're right
why wouldn't it follow that the flu shot
should be illegal you said it's criminal
to mandate the flu shot because it kills
people in my age category
so if you had to cast the deciding vote
if you had decided to run for congress
instead of doing the great work you've
done
over so many years and you were the
deciding vote in the united states
senate
and there was a bill to outlaw the flu
shot wouldn't why wouldn't you vote for
it
if you you know i'm kind of a free
market
i i think you know what i'm against
mandates
i think that you know there may be
situations where
you know that where that product might
do some good for somebody but
i don't i just don't believe it should
be mandated i don't
you know i wouldn't think
for example at a um
viagra should be mandated to
every human being on the planet right
but there may be somebody who says you
know i want to take that medication let
them do it
but let's order everybody to do it look
you're we you and i are on the same page
there i'm curious what you think of this
because i feel very strongly about this
let's assume you have a drug a
pharmaceutical
that hasn't been tested that is
potentially dangerous
but has a 10 chance of curing pancreatic
cancer in terminally ill patients
do you agree with me and with president
trump on this
issue that individuals who are dying
should have the opportunity to go off
label and to take
dangerous drugs that probably will kill
them
but increase the chances that they
remain
alive that that should be a matter of
individual choice
i'm i'm i have a big libertarian streak
in me i think
people should be left to their own
choices wherever possible
unless it's going to do some harm to
others let me address
one just one last thing that you agree
with
you know you said well if it's deficit
against the placebo and this
i think is why people like me are
suspicious
are reticent um the oxford vaccine
which is you know was the is the other
leader it's a
gate says a huge investment in it fauci
is pushing it it
is the leader astrazeneca is now you
know
is branding it that vaccine is run by a
guy called greg pollard who is at
oxford a very very famous powerful
virologist
he originally promised at the beginning
he said we're going to test it against
the placebo we're going to do what's
never been done in vaccinology before
we're going to actually use
an inert placebo intestine
and then in the middle of his phase two
he said no we're going to test it
against the meningitis vaccine the
meningitis vaccine is a vaccine with a
really
high injury profile it has listed just
on its manufacturing insert are
50 deadly serious injuries including
kawasaki disease
on guillain-barre paralysis
or heart attacks and death
and and hepatitis and all kinds of
autoimmune diseases
it's probably it's arguably the most
dangerous vaccine so
instead of giving his placebo group an
inert placebo
he's giving him the most dangerous
vaccine he why
it's a ploy that vaccinologists use and
they give their placebo group something
that's horrendously dangerous
to mask injuries in the vaccine
and you know and so everybody on my side
sees this and they say he's not being on
it we do not know what the risk profile
of that product is
we are never going to take that product
because it was never tested against a
placebo
make them do the science don't say to
you know get
angry at people who are skeptical and
say
oh you're skeptical we're watching the
sausage get made
and it's an ugly process and by the way
he gave that vaccine to a bunch of
monkeys
you know what macaques and then
and then he exposed he challenged the
macaques by exposing them to the wild
coronavirus
yeah yeah and all of the macaques got
sick
so the vaccine doesn't work but because
the british government put 90
000 pounds into it he now is in order to
make two million doses
with a vaccine we know doesn't work
and they're going forward with it anyway
and he refuses to test it against the
placebo so that gives us
zero faith so
let me first of all say nobody should be
angry you people should be praising you
for bringing this to the attention of
the american public
let me just summarize if i can my view
and then you can get the last word
um i am thrilled that we had this debate
i think the public
watching the debate has learned uh we've
learned how much we agree about we're
both libertarians we both agree with
john stewartville
that the government shouldn't be
compelling you to do anything just for
your own good but
they can compel you to do things that
prevent harm to others
we have some disagreements about
mandates i think we both agree that any
vaccine should start out by being
offered voluntarily
both agree that people should be
offered the vaccine initially and take
it on a voluntary basis
and that mandatory vaccination which
presents very
daunting moral and constitutional issues
should not be required until it's proved
absolutely necessary by the consensus of
medical opinion i think we also agree
that the first amendment and the spirit
of the first amendment requires that
this debate continue
and so i'm pleased that we had this
debate you've persuaded me
about some of the medical issues i will
look further into medical issues
i don't think i've persuaded you on the
constitutional issues and
i know you haven't persuaded me on the
constitutional issues
i still take the position of the winter
democracy the courts do have the final
word
that i do believe that if there were
legislation
mandating in extreme circumstances with
safety
and other considerations taken into
account
mandatory vaccination i do believe the
supreme court
would and should uphold mandatory
vaccination under those circumstances
that's the major area we disagree with
but in practical terms
i suspect we don't have a lot of
disagreement that will come to fruition
in the next year or so because in the
next year the big issue will be how to
get the vaccine voluntarily
to as many people as possible who are
willing to take it
and so thank you for putting together
this debate i think it
really was informative and thank you
robert for uh
accepting the idea of debating on this
issue
thank you alan and i i want to express
my gratitude to you
on behalf of myself and
everybody in this community you know
people who are who are called
anti-facts they're mainly not
anti-vaccine
almost all of them are the mothers and
fathers of
intellectually disabled kids who gave
all the vaccines who did what they were
told and then their child was injured
and they and that prompted them to go
out and do the research
those people should be allowed to speak
those people
should not be gagged they should not be
they should not be
considered heretics they should be
allowed to tell their story
and they should be treated with
compassion and
understanding and patience and
an intellectual openness toward their
stories they shouldn't be vilified they
shouldn't be gaslighted
they shouldn't be ignored and right now
particularly at a point in our history
where we're talking about
giving lots of people this vaccine their
stories are more important to you than
ever
i want to thank you because for 15 years
all of us have been trying to do
a debate and we haven't been able to get
peter hotez to do it but paul offit
ian lipkin any of the leaders i've been
have been scared to sit where you are
now
and i want to thank you so much on
behalf of
all of us but also our democratic
traditions for coming here
thank you alan well thank you robert
gentlemen one thing i do want to say is
i'm glad i got through my 28 questions
with you guys it was uh very good and uh
i know one thing is we have to make this
disclaimer that this
this debate is not sponsored by viagra
even though
robert brought up viagra and i'll make
sure next time we're in
boston i avoid taking you to my favorite
sushi spot since you are anti-fish i had
no clue until today's debate that robert
is anti-fish
uh and by the way based on how this goes
if the audience comes back we may reach
out to you for part two again
if there's other topics we can uh touch
up
thank you so much for your robert thank
you so much for your time take care
everybody appreciate you guys
thank you thank you very much patrick so
can you imagine for 15 years robert
kennedy has been waiting for one person
to want to debate the issue of vaccine
and alan dershowitz the attorney
constitutional lawyer
finally said yes and this took place you
had a chance to watch both of them go at
it
i'm curious to know if either one of
them changed your mind comment below
and on top of that you know what i'd
like to see take place is to get someone
who's a doctor
any one of them off it hotels anybody
that you would like to see debate
go on twitter and tweet them and myself
saying we'd like to see a debate
robert kennedy on valuetainment and
outside of that look i got two other
interviews i want you to watch one of
them is my full interview i do with
robert kennedy which is an even deeper
interview on the topic of vaccine than
this one if you've not watched a click
over here
and the other one is a debate format
that we had
about a year ago where we had two folks
come somebody who was from u.s navy
intelligence and another person that was
the director of a
developmental director from normal and
they debated marijuana we went to
cocaine alcohol
very very good debate live right here in
my office if you've not watched that
click over here
and if this topic of vaccine is
important to you
you are directly or indirectly affected
by this
help share this video and the topic
started out there by people talking
about it whether you're pro or anti
share this video with others facebook
twitter text whatever it may be
so we can get a lot of eyeballs for
people start talking about this debate
as we're getting closer to possibility
of a mandated vaccine for coronavirus
and if you enjoyed the video today
please click the subscribe button take
care everybody bye